c'est un proche de pierre au début
puisqu'on a fait pratiquement notre
arrivée en 88,90 ensemble et c'était un
garçon un grand un grand dégingandé avec
cette coupe en peinture
qui était très drôle qui était ce qui
était assez lunaire je racontais cette
anecdote justement dans le reportage la
première fois que nous sommes allés au
restaurant bon évidemment je suis
l'adulte j'ai 10 ans plus que lui nous
sommes du même signe et puis nous
entendons bien lui il aime le côté
imitateur de femme chez moi parce que
c'est une espèce de puis il veut
m'amener déjà dans les bois de guerre un
petit peu sauf que j'arrive là-bas c'est
un peu le service à la pompe donc je me
demandais ce que je vais faire là il me
dit il me dit c'est oui
le terme est peut-être très approprié
mais
en tout cas en tout cas je me retrouve
avec ça et on va donc au restaurant et
il me dit
voilà l'édition livre d'or et là je me
suis dit mais quel
c'est là où j'ai parlé un petit peu
d'arrogance mais presque une arrogance
poétique parce qu'il y avait quelque
chose d'un peu cheval ce que j'avais il
y avait du panache chez ce garçon-là il
y avait beaucoup de douceur d'humanité
et c'est ce qui m'a c'est ce qui m'a plu
ce qui est extrêmement généreux c'est un
garçon qui qui a besoin qu'on l'aime
donc du coup quelque part il paye il
avait fait un très bon sketch la maman
qui s'appelait je voudrais louer des
amis et en fait ça ressemble un petit
peu à la vérité à sa vérité c'est à dire
que c'est un garçon qui n'aimait rien
tant que d'être entouré et d'être aimé
alors on est fini vous pouvez y aller
j'adore Patrick je peux l'écouter des
heures ça alors le documentaire fait
aussi le lien entre les premières
consommations de drogue de pierre et ils
sont homosexualité qui est un fardeau
pour lui jusqu'à son arrivée à Paris
regardez en réalité la fête et ses
paradis artificielles sont d'abord un
refuge une fuite en avant contre un mal
être qui ronge le comédien depuis
l'enfance son homosexualité j'ai grandi
avec l'homosexualité qui était un délit
qui était donc pénalisé je suis arrivé à
Paris où là il y avait un milieu gay la
nuit parisienne était très très
accueillante pour pour les homos et là
je me suis éclaté mais trop je suis
parti parce que j'ai découvert l'alcool
et la drogue qui m'ont aidé à ne plus me
juger mal en tant qu'Homo parce qu'à
l'époque je me jugeais mal je me dis oh
merde pourquoi je suis homo ça aurait
été tellement plus simple d'être hétéro
alors dans cette première partie aussi
il y a 30 ans déjà Palmade Pierre
Palmade avait déjà été visée par une
perquisition liée à la drogue c'était en
92 regardez 24 décembre 1992 le nom de
Pierre Palmade est une première fois
associée à la cocaïne il raconte sans
farce son arrestation dans son
autobiographie il est 7h du matin on
frappe à la porte de l'appartement que
j'habite dans le 16e arrondissement de
Paris je glisse un œil dans le judas 4
ou 5 flics sur le palier j'ouvre ils
entrent comme dans un film l'un des
policiers appelle son chef on a trouvé
quelque chose c'est évidemment de la
coque j'avoue tout notamment ma
consommation substantielle j'en suis à 5
grammes par semaine 20 grammes par mois
en fait on voit déjà à ce moment là son
addiction et aussi l'obligation qu'il va
avoir de financer ça c'est à dire qu'il
va y avoir un piège autour de lui
peut-être l'avez-vous connu mais il doit
trouver de l'argent pour financer alors
quand ça rentre c'est très bien mais à
des moments où il y a moins de travail
ça va devenir très compliqué pour lui
enfin il a rarement été au chômage je
veux dire qu'il écrivait déjà des pièces
il a écrit pour les plus grands il y
avait des droits d'auteur qui était
assez conséquent il avait beaucoup
beaucoup de gala donc je pense pas qu'il
manquait par contre il y avait une
surenchère au niveau de la consommation
de drogue c'est ça peut-être qui
[Musique]
est dans le documentaire d'hier soir
c'est que je trouve qu'on a un peu
victimisé dans la manière dont c'était
raconté c'est-à-dire qu'on a pris sa vie
et son parcours et ses démons alors pas
vous un entrepreneur d'intervention mais
la manière dont il le racontait comme
une circonstance atteignante le fait que
il assume pas du tout sa sexualité le
fait qu'il qu'il soit sans qu'il est
sombré dans la drogue comme si ça
expliquait ce qu'il avait fait mon on
est d'accord que c'est pas du tout
excusable et que les familles des
victimes elles s'en foutent complètement
de ses failles maintenant d'après ce qui
est arrivé si on en est au début de sa
carrière il faut voir que nous pour les
derniers mois
lorsqu'il a annulé notre dernière
représentation théâtre des Mathurins
enfin il l'a même pas annulé il est pas
venu donc voilà le lendemain il nous
envoie ce texto dont on avait parlé une
récemment et et il nous dit la coke me
détruit la vie voilà il était en état de
venir encore moins de nous prévenir mais
la côte ma ma drogue me détruit la vie
donc quelque part il est quand même un
peu victime enfin on est quand même dans
un milieu si on revient sur les années
90 les années 2000 qui est arrivé il y a
un bébé qui est mort
quelques jours excusez-moi
non mais c'est pas entendre le bébé
serait qui a perdu la jeune femme serait
né dans quelques jours et vous dites que
non non non
pour tout à fait c'est difficile à
entendre c'est pas dans la deuxième
partie là il parle des dérives de Pierre
Palmade il y a quelques années Pierre
Palmade découvre les fameux soirées de
Cam sex dont on a beaucoup parlé depuis
l'accident et cette découverte signe
début de la fin c'est ce qu'ils disent
regarde
la découverte une nouvelle drogue qui
permet une activité sexuelle à haut
risque le camsexe tout se passe chez moi
avec un mec de ou trois ce sont de
longues heures qui durent toute la nuit
parfois la journée suivante on rit on
regarde la télé on parle on est à poil
on fume on couche aille ensemble et on
recommence c'est une orgie amusante à
force de repousser toujours plus loin la
limite Pierre Palmade a perdu beaucoup
d'amis plusieurs producteurs ont jeté
l'éponge le nom de Palmade ne remplit
plus les sales comme avant mais ses amis
les plus proches refusent pour l'instant
de l'abandonner
oui là c'est la fuite totale dans le la
fameuse 3 MMC notamment les molécules
ils découvrent ça et pour moi ce que
j'ai aimé dans le reportage c'est que là
effectivement c'est progressif comme
vous le montrer Cyril et là il a encore
un entourage autour de lui mais après il
va perdre tout le monde je sais pas si
vous l'avez connu à ce moment-là déjà où
les drogues de synthèse ont commencé à
briser sa vie on a on a commencé enfin
il y a très longtemps je veux dire qu'on
est plus en rapport moi j'allais le voir
parce qu'il avait tous les il avait ce
qu'on appelle la bande à Palmade avec
Camille Cottin notamment on allait le
voir
et donc on allait le voir à ce moment-là
et moi je me rappelle que très souvent
elle me disait on mange après mais après
une première expérience qui avait été un
rattache total on avait passé la soirée
ensemble on va au restaurant il découvre
Dorothée il ne fait que lui parler je
reste donc seul face à l'entrecôte et
après je vais payer mon écho et ils me
disent j'espère que tu as passé une
bonne soirée et je lui dis oui mais
c'était pas ce soir
et voilà tout était comme ça je les
pouvais nous planter au dernier moment
il pouvait nous inviter et puis en fait
ne pas être là donc il y a très
longtemps je veux dire qu'on a appris
tous des distances tout en ayant la même
affection parce qu'on sait le on sait
c'est des mots qui le dévorent on sait
la fragilité de du mec il a tout tenté
il a même tenté le mariage parce qu'à un
moment on a rigolé moi j'étais au
mariage et il draguait à côté des
garçons on se regardait avec un
Roumanoff on se disait mais il est stone
mais c'est symptomatique c'est à dire
que le fait de un jour se marier avec
une femme alors que tu sais pertinemment
que tu es homo ça veut dire que tu as
une souffrance qui est extrême sur le
fait que tu te détestes et que tu
n'assumes pas qui tu es alors pour
quelle raison il y a plein de raisons
mais il y a aussi le fait que la société
t'aide pas à t'assumer aussi et quand on
parlait tout à l'heure quand vous dites
que il est pas victime certes il est pas
victime parce que la finalité de tous
parcours elle est mortifère mais il est
quelque part aussi victime de sa propre
vie et tous ces démons là à la drogue et
tout bah on peut pas lui enlever ce
statut de victime aussi à lui avant à ce
drame là tu vois surtout qu'il a pas été
nécessairement entouré puisque les gens
l'ont quand même beaucoup abandonné
c'est pas que je défends mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'on peut pas balayer
tout un parcours uniquement
malheureusement parce qu'il y a eu un
drame
il promet à tous ses proches qui s'est
mis au vert en achetant cette fameuse
maison de Cély-en-Bière objectif ne pas
perdre ces derniers amis qui le
soutiennent depuis trop d'années regarde
il en parlait énormément ça l'aidait
d'en parler semble-t-il comme il avait
promis à Régine avant-hier à Muriel
Robin le lendemain et à moi le
surlendemain et à Michel Laroque
après-demain évidemment il faut que je
tienne ma parole parce que sinon ces
quatre là au moins pour me prendre pour
un pour un rigolo donc ça l'aidait d'en
parler de nous dire non ça y est là je
crois que c'est bon puis en tout cas
regardez voir ça fait quoi un mois et
demi que je ne suis qu'au jus d'orange
bon pierre
alors pour traiter ces addictions il
décide de débourser une somme folle pour
une cure en Tunisie c'est ça absolument
il est parti en Tunisie ça devait durer
longtemps et puis finalement et bien il
n'a pas pu suivre jusqu'au bout cette
cure c'est pas très sympathique une
clinique haut de gamme oui très cher
absolument et ils ont d'ailleurs
retrouvé dans le reportage quelqu'un qui
l'avait suivi à ce moment-là c’était un
passage intéressant regarde le problème
de date 2 ans avant l'accident il va
tenter une fois encore d'échapper à ses
démons à plus de 1700 km de chez lui
il s'envole alors pour la Tunisie
direction la Villa Paradiso une clinique
haut de gamme spécialisée dans le
traitement des addictions le comédien
doit y suivre une cure de 28 jours pour
un montant de 15000 euros un membre du
personnel présent lors de son admission
à la clinique décrite un homme très
affaibli Pierre Palmade a rejoint la
clinique dans un état physique et
psychologique instable le sevrage était
très difficile et les signes de manque
intenses il était introverti répondait
peu aux tentatives de l'équipe de le
faire parler selon cette source il a
finalement quitté la clinique au bout
d'une semaine de cure seulement
une des multiples cures qu'il a suivi et
qui ont qui n'ont pas abouti il en a
fait que trois absolument trois c'est
beaucoup quand même ce qui fait dire aux
gens qu'en fait c'était un peu
velléitaire il n'avait pas réellement
envie de guérir je sais pas si vous avez
vu de cette manière là on a cette
impression ouais vous dites qu'il y
avait un problème moi je me demande même
si c'était pas un acte manqué à la fin
un moment faut faire que ça expose enfin
fallait que ça se termine sauf que ça
c'est très mal terminé parce que là qui
se bute tout seul à la James in oui mais
qui d'autre non et vous disiez qu'il y a
un problème de date c'est quoi ça vous
disais ça pendant le voilà Tunisie je
crois et pour la Tunisie c'est à dire
premier pays producteur de date c'est
tout c'est tout je vais y aller je vais
y aller alors c'est pas grave tu as
raison alors la descente aux enfer
continue après pour Pierre Palma qui
continue d'avoir un très gros train de
vie sans avoir d'entrée suffisante
d'argent c'est ça là c'est ça absolument
il lui fallait de plus en plus de
besoins et de moins en moins de rentrer
de moins en moins de gala son nom
commence à être moins populaire donc
voilà 6000 euros nécessaires pour
acheter la drogue 5000 euros de rentrée
le déficit se creuse à ce moment-là et
il commence à devoir de l'argent à
l'URSSAF au fiscaux ça fait quand même
aller on va dire 30 ans que les droits
d'auteur de pierre sont pas de 6000
euros par mois sans vouloir c'est
beaucoup plus mais
il a écrit des scénarios régulièrement à
la télé les parents les la
finalités
Palmas juste un petit décalage de 1000
euros c'est beaucoup d'argent mais c'est
que 1000 euros quelque part moi je pense
qu'il peut arriver à couvrir et puis je
pense qu'il est emprunté à beaucoup de
monde je pense que très franchement nous
on a vu dans les derniers spectacles
qu'on produisait pour lui
les productions du colonel je vais pas
le dire mais c'est vrai que bon ben il
avait besoin de faire rentrer de
l'argent faut être faut être réaliste
regardez
à la campagne les hauts murs de son
refuge ont laissé s'engouffrer le vice
et la fête sans limite il a pris ses
quartiers cette maison il l'a mise en
vente en décembre dernier pour un
million 365000 euros car il est criblé
de dettes il doit 250 000 euros à
l'URSSAF et aux impôts notamment et
garde un train de vie au-dessus de ses
moyens 6000 euros de dépenses contre
5000 euros de revenus mensuels
ça irait on est on est assez on est
assez loin des ravites
de terre en plus au moment où il était
en Tunisie et il jouait au Théâtre des
Enfants du Paradis oui j'ai une pièce à
deux réalités
normalement le prix moyen pour un pour
en faire Palma ça doit être dans les
15000 dans les 15000 pour la soirée mais
vous avez toute une équipe une technique
des éclairages des régisseurs des des
miroirs
quand ils ont fait la tournée avec Robin
et la tournée avec Michel Laroque
c'était des salles des Zénith qui
doublaient
ce chiffre de 6000 euros par mois
c'est rejoué par d'autres artistes mais
forcément c'est lui l'auteur qui touche
toujours c'est n'importe c'est comme la
fine équipe sur France Télévisions
essaye il a très bien vendu la fine
équipe et on sait très bien que France
Télévision paye beaucoup et très cher
dans le la troisième partie de ce
documentaire BFM révèle donc ensuite des
infos sur le fameux accident du 10
février dernier et dévoile les
participants à la session camsex
organisé chez lui écouter le programme
ce jeudi 9 février c'est bien ici qu'il
invite trois amis des mauvais jours à
venir combler sa solitude mossine e33
ans sans bouger 34 ans qui lui vient
d'être condamné pour trafic de
stupéfiants et Camille qui fréquente
Pierre Palmade depuis quatre ans tous
connaissent le programme de la fête qui
s'annonce cocaïne drogue de synthèse et
sexe plusieurs jours d'affilés
alors c'est vrai ça
visiblement
un endroit festif avec de la drogue et
c'est participant qui sont donc ceux qui
l'ont accompagné en suite donc voilà
Camille va expliquer qu'elle est que ce
Camille est parti au milieu de la fête
mais les deux autres sont restés voilà
et de temps en temps même l'inverse
parce que quand on a fait ce spectacle
au Théâtre de hier le 21 octobre il
devait le taxi devait le ramener à sa
maison de campagne et nous y fait non
ben non on va ramener moi à Paris parce
que j'ai un peu envie de faire la fête
ce soir donc donc visiblement c'est
aussi l'inverse je pense que oui on est
quand on voit le doc là on peut pas
s'empêcher de poser la question est-ce
que le drame aurait pu être évité moi
j'étais surpris de voir que la première
arrestation par la police elle était il
y a 30 ans on l'a vu tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'il y a pas un proche à un
moment tu l'as dit parce que si il
partait tout seul lecture est-ce qu'il y
a pas un proche je te dis non tu restes
jusqu'à ce que tu sois guéri parce que
c'était quasiment écrit qui allait ce
drame qui allait arriver mais vous
croyez qu'avec avec un pire Palma vous
pouvez lui dire maintenant tu sors plus
de toi tu rentres enferme dans la
chambre il m'a dit si jamais tu me vois
prendre une bouteille tu me tu me fous
une claque je suis parti aux toilettes
je vais dire il est revenu il avait une
bouteille il m'a dit m'emmerde pas
dégage notre dernier spectacle
d'ailleurs il nous a dit pas de vin pas
d'alcool machin coca zéro non non donc
il faisait aussi des efforts un de ses
compagnons de défonce il était pas censé
être avec lui puisque normalement il
devait pas le l'approcher donc ça veut
dire
dans dans toute dispositif judiciaire il
y a eu quand même des failles qui ont
permis à ce sans bout d'être avec
surtout des feuilles il y a quelques
années quand il a été appréhendé qu'il a
eu qu'une une amende de 1500 euros
qu'est-ce que c'est 1500 € pour Pierre
Palmade dire alors qu'il est piqué avec
des avec de la drogue c'était quoi
c'était quoi c'était une amende parce
que effectivement il y avait une
détention détention et usage de
stupéfiants c'était la première alerte
la première condamnation qui pourrait
faire que il y aura une récidive
éventuellement dans le dernier drame
qu'est-ce qu'une condamnation à 1500
euros pour un type qui en gagne
le drame c'est qu'on est dans la
caricature du show-biz pour être
objectif
exactement
on a vu toutes les draps aux États-Unis
les Whitney Houston
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour éviter
aux soirées
oui oui moi je suis allé puis moi j'ai
vu que c'était pas que du sucre je suis
parti non parce que je sucre beaucoup
mon café donc on en sait rien donc vous
êtes déjà non sérieusement oui bien sûr
alors moi
c'est ça
le tournoi de tennis des personnalités
par semaine donc j'étais plutôt un mec
sportif
direct ah oui oui je suis repartir mais
j'ai fait exactement comme comme
François Rollin on n'était pas branché
par les mêmes choses un petit coup de
vin ok alors après déjà
et ses amis ressortent le soir de
l'accident dans le documentaire il
retasse et le retrace ce qui s'est passé
diffuse le témoignage du vieil homme qui
a été impliqué dans l'accident c'est la
première fois que ce monsieur parle dans
les médias regardez avant 19h le
comédien monte à bord de sa voiture
accompagné cette fois de maussine et
Sambou sans bouger a proposé justement à
Pierre Palmade de conduire parce qu'il
était pas en état et Pierre Palmade a
refusé il voulait conduire alors que 30
minutes avant il était encore en train
de s'injecter des drogues de synthèse
les trois hommes prennent la route au
même moment à Dammarie-les-Lys une autre
voiture s'engage sur la chaussée celle
de Yuksel Yakut avec son fils de vrime
assis à l'arrière il raccompagne chez
elle sa belle-sœur enceinte de 7 mois
juste derrière un troisième véhicule
conduit par un homme de 87 ans
62 je sais puisque je suis la voiture
que depuis le rond-point je suis à 40
mètres derrière face à eux la voiture
conduite par Pierre Palmade la voiture
arrive en face et arrivée à la hauteur
de la voiture et d'un coup de volant il
a percute de plein fouet
c'est la première fois
c'est un vrai témoignage ce qu'on ignore
encore c'est la vitesse pour le moment
les expertises n'ont pas donné leur
verdict et est-ce qu'il y a une
défaillance où est-ce qu'il y a une
autre raison à ce coup de volant brutal
qui est arrivé voilà et il faut dire
aussi que Pierre Palma était déjà sorti
dans la journée vous l'avez révélé Cyril
il était sorti déjà une première fois
pour acheter des seringues c'est
mossigne qui a révélé ça ils ont acheté
des seringues et puis il est ressorti
pour aller effectivement au
ravitaillement à Villiers-en-Bière et
dans tout cela il y a trois victimes oui
oui il faut penser à elle justement
il était tous les trois ensemble avec
une autre personne et il dit que lui il
se rappelle de rien qui dormait etc et
qui ne voulait surtout pas répondre en
l'entendu dit non je veux pas en parler
je vais pas en parler genre comme s'il
était complètement
dans la voiture ont aussi parlé pour la
première fois il ne rien et l'un d'entre
eux est encore sous le choc écouté
nous avons contacté ces deux passagers
qui avaient pris la fuite après la
collision le premier sans bouger nous a
reçu chez lui en banlieue parisienne et
nous a confié être très perturbé depuis
le drame selon lui juste avant
l'accident pierre Palma devrait reçu un
texto sur son téléphone portable qui lui
aurait demandé de lire avant de dévier
soudainement sur la gauche mossine eux a
lui affirmé aux enquêteurs qu'il dormait
à l'arrière de la voiture avant
l'accident nous l'avons contacté par
téléphone vous souvenez un petit peu de
du contexte dans lequel l'accident s'est
produit
parce que les souvenirs sont douloureux
va pas être médisant mais ça sent un peu
le coup de l'avocat c'est-à-dire vous ne
dites rien
est-ce que c'est pas une défense une
autre en ce qui peut pas trop parler
wigo juste sur le volet
pédopornographique il faut savoir qu'il
y a aucune accusation qui a été retenue
contre lui et ça pose quand même
question sur l'emballement judiciaire
qui a eu suite à ça parce qu'on part
quand même du dénonciation par téléphone
donc un média appeler pour dire Pierre
Palmade a des vidéos pédopornographiques
ils ont fait deux perquisitions
immédiatement tous les médias n'ont
parlé donc c'est quand même un
emballement à partir d'un simple coup de
fil mais il y a aucune accusation il y a
rien il y a rien de plus simple que de
mettre un type qui est déjà en état
comme ça devant un film
pédopornographique et de prendre avec
une caméra
faire un petit reportage de ça et de et
de balancer après on peut avoir des gens
aussi qui regardent pas ce genre de truc
dans son environnement
bien sûr voilà alors Gilles Verdez on en
est où là maintenant alors on en est à
une phase extrêmement nouvelle c'est à
dire que Pierre Palmade va pouvoir
quitter Villejuif il va donc aller à
Bordeaux vous l'avez annoncé pourquoi
Bordeaux il y a plusieurs raisons
Bordeaux c'est ça terme natale Bordeaux
les enquêteurs pensent qu'il va être
coupé de ses potentiels
approvisionnements parisiens donc une
sorte d'exil comme ça et au CHU de
Bordeaux il y a une section addictologie
comportement addictive qui est
extrêmement performante lui il sera en
soins et en réadaptation donc ils vont
pouvoir le suivre on avait évoqué Cyril
bouge en souvenez des cliniques privées
vous aviez évoqué monté vidéo et moi je
pensais également à une clinique au
Vésinet qui sont réputées pour soigner
les personnalités en rapport au lambda
exactement alors le problème de ces
cliniques privées juste une chose c'est
qu'effectivement quand même Bordeaux
n'est pas non plus totalement anodin
parce que sa sœur habite à Bordeaux
elle va aussi remettre
c'est pas le même traitement pour tout
le monde pour trouver ben je trouve que
cette oui oui c'est c'est pas le même
traitement c'est parce qu'il s'appelle
Pierre Palmade que va y avoir sûrement
une une jurisprudence Pierre Palmade par
rapport à la décision de justice je
pense qu'un pékin moyen je lui en aura
pas toutes ces pensées vraiment ouais je
pense vraiment c'est certain c'est
certain et il y aurait une polémique il
était parti en clinique privée je vous
explique pourquoi qui paye tout
simplement qui paye c'est à dire que
quand vous allez dans ces cliniques
privées c'est plusieurs milliers d'euros
par jour ok il faut payer la suite
l'hébergement etc si vous n'avez pas de
mutuelle je sais pas s'il en a une si
vous n'avez pas de mutuelle ça coûte
très cher est-ce que le contribuable
aurait payé lui visiblement ne peut pas
payer donc le CHU terrain public la
maison est en vente et la partie il a
quand même un appartement à Paris la
maison ne se vend pas voilà donc
Bordeaux ça semble le juge a donné son
aval ça semble un lieu où peut-être
pourra-t-il poursuivre son processus et
suivre continuer à suivre cette cure